[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
15 mars manger local une priorité pour
les français ce jeudi soir au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération a consacré une
conférence circuits courts et de
proximité
ce vendredi les jeunes en grève scolaire
mondiale pour le climat une sèche les
cours pour alerter les dirigeants sur
les conditions climatiques nous
recevrons olivier paréja élus
écologistes de guyancourt pour faire le
point face à cette urgence
environnementale visite dans les
yvelines des ministres jean michel
blanquer air et christophe castaner
point sur le chantier a pris la fuite
d'hydrocarbures ou encore 14e édition de
la semaine nationale du rein
comme chaque vendredi coup d'oeil sur
l'actualité de la semaine
on vient de l'apprendre le tribunal de
versailles vient de rendre sa décision
dans le procès concernant l'abattoir 2
août dans le dernier abattoir porcin
d'île de france
rappelez-vous deux militants de
l'association l214 s'étaient introduits
illégalement sur le site et avait filmé
l'étourdissement des ports au ce2 et
porter est pointé du doigt l'usagé
intensif de l'aiguillon électrique par
des employés le verdict est tombé les
juges ont prononcé des peines d'amendés
2500 euros contre le directeur vincent
hareng il devra également rembourser
avec ses trois anciens salariés et un
agent public les frais d'avocats de neuf
associations de défense des animaux
les cinq personnes condamnées dispose
d'un délai de dix jours pour faire appel
de la décision
l'avocat de vincent harang a déjà
indiqué prendre cette voie
saint quentin en yvelines poursuit son
cycle de conférences autour de la ville
et de l'agriculture ce jeudi soir se
tenait à la scène nationale le troisième
volet consacré aux circuits courts et de
proximité
le reportage de mélanie poquet les
circuits courts utopie ou réalité pour
sa troisième conférence a grillé urba
saint quentin en yvelines et les réseau
des médiathèques se sont penchés sur la
question
saint quentin en yvelines a choisi
à prendre en compte l'aspect agricole
dans l'ensemble de son projet de
territoire comme une part intégrante à
la fois d'aménagement à la fois
de développement économique et puis
également de vie citoyenne elle la
france compte un agriculteur pour 128
personnes à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un pour 11 mais l'habitant les
circuits courts véhicules pas mal de
d'angélisme une part de d'idéalisation
parfois on peut penser que les circuits
courts vont résoudre tous les problèmes
alimentaires ou les problèmes les
questions agricoles et en fait
évidemment ce n'est qu'une petite part
de des modes de production
enfin des moyens de production agricole
trente deux exploitations agricoles sont
sur le territoire saint quentinois et
quenza maps ou le relais d'une
agriculture de proximité comme 100%
villepreux créé en 2016 et une centaine
d'adhérents à ce jour c'est pas si
simple de créer une amap de trouver des
partenaires et surtout de
le site et mamad fonctionne de manière à
ce que la marque soit là pour soutenir
les partenaires et particulièrement les
maraîchers parce que c'est quand même
une économique est fragile
une dernière conférence est prévue le 16
mai prochain ce dernier rendez-vous
s'attardera sur l'agriculture urbaine
olivier paréja bonjour bonjour vous êtes
élu écologiste à guyancourt on va faire
le point avec vous sur la grève mondial
sur le climat mais avant une petite
réaction concernant ce sujet les
circuits courts
est ce que certains agriculteurs ne
serait-il pas avec ce terme pas toujours
clair dans l'esprit des gens alors
effectivement il ya de la définition et
puis ça nous a été rappelé dans la
conférence d'hier soir qui était
effectivement très intéressant
le terme mais pas nécessairement très
bien définis circuits courts ça veut
surtout dire peu d'intermédiaire et donc
vendre directement à un grand
distributeur c'est aussi un circuit
court donc ce qu'il faut qu'on voit
aussi ses six qui nous intéresse c'est
limiter la distance pour éviter de les
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
par exemple et donc effectivement il ya
une définition par contre ce qui était
bien présent hier soir et qui a été
rappelé dans l'interview à l'instant
c'est que on a vraiment envie c'est
qu'il ya de plus en plus de gens qui ont
envie d'aller vers ce mode de
distribution
et c'est bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui
est qui est derrière tout ça c'est que
les gens veulent le plus de confiance
retrouvée le lien avec l'agriculteur
savoir d'où viennent leurs produits est
sûr que les produits sont sains et ça
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
très intéressant alors je le rappelle
olivier paréja vous êtes conseiller
municipal à guyancourt
hier soir les professeurs du lycée villa
roy étaient mobilisés de 19 heures à 23
heures près de vingt enseignants ont
occupé l'établissement pour s'opposer à
la réforme du lycée
dès la rentrée prochaine les filières
générales s l et es seront supprimés
pour les élèves de seconde qui passeront
en première à la place un bac à la carte
avec des enseignements obligatoires et
le choix de spécialités
ce collectif de professeurs dénoncent
notamment le flou qui entoure les
futures épreuves et des mensonges de la
part du ministre de l'éducation
nationale
écoutez aînés réaction au micro de
gregory k d'aller notamment autour de
l'idée que les élèves rien un libre
choix de spécialités qui pourrait
choisir
effectivement le type de bac qui
souhaitent passer alors qu'en fait dans
la réalité le les contraintes du de
l'enseignement supérieur vont les
contraindre à les obliger à faire des
choix qui sont cohérents par rapport à
filières de l'enseignement supérieur
donc en fait il ya un gros risque de
reconstitution des filières dès la
rentrée prochaine les élèves de première
dès le mois de janvier seront évalués
donc on dénote qui compteront pour le
baccalauréat donc avec des systèmes de
partiel un petit peu comme à la fac qui
font que
en fait les élèves seront sous pression
permanente et ses professeurs demandent
un report de la réforme ou au moins un
moratoire afin de pouvoir mener une
concertation
autre mouvement de grève en ce mois de
mars les jeunes se mobilisent face à
l'urgence environnementale ce vendredi
les lycéens et étudiants de toute la
france se mobilise pour la grève
mondiale pour le climat
alors que le mois de février a été
marqué par des températures très chaudes
et un record d'ensoleillement les
étudiants appellent à ne pas aller en
cours et réclame des actions des
gouvernements pour endiguer le
changement climatique
c'est un pas considérable que les jeunes
se saisissent de cette question
environnementale olivier parent et
chasse c'est naturel c'est logique que
les jeunes interpelle les gens qui sont
aujourd'hui en charge des décisions pour
dire mais qu'est ce que vous êtes en
train de nous laisser quelle terre vous
allez nous laisser et donc c'est tout à
fait logique que cette génération bouge
et qu'on voit qui ne se passe rien
depuis des années que eux s'impatientent
moi je trouve ça tout à fait logique
tout à fait logique alors il souhaite
notamment l'application de la
déclaration d'un état d'urgence
climatique et sociale
une revendication applicables selon vous
tout à fait l'exemple comprend
habituellement de se dire il ya un petit
peu plus de dix ans on a mis de l'ordre
de 5000 milliards pour le problème des
banques qui étaient en faillite au
moment de la crise de 2008 et quand l'ue
la commission européenne estime ce qu'il
faudrait pour que l'europe vivent dans
un mode durable c'est 3,5 milliers de
milliards donc ça veut dire 3,5 par
rapport aux 5 qu'on a été capable de
débloquer donc ça veut dire que c'est
premier avec 5 jusqu'à 2030 donc c'est
pas immédiatement donc ça veut dire que
l'argent il y donc c'est vraiment la
décision politique le courage politique
qui n'y est pas et c'est logique que que
les jeunes interpelle et moi quand je
voyais la carte du monde où on peut voir
les 1000
500 appels il y en a partout sur la
planète et ça c'est quelque part
réjouissant de la mobilisation il faut
maintenant que ça fasse pression et que
ça change quelque chose
76,1 % des lycéens sont prêts à voter
pour un parti écologiste seulement
sondage dj school
ce mouvement a débuté en août 2010 8 est
l'initiatrice greta tanberg une
adolescente suédoise de 16 ans chaque
vendredi elles sèchent les cours pour
manifester devant le parlement de son
pays
elle demande la justice climatique et
sociale
depuis cette initiative a essaimé dans
plusieurs pays d'europe
un mouvement qui va perdurer en france
voilà je sais pas répondre à la place
des lycéens et des étudiants
mais d'un autre côté il ya urgence il
faut faire quelque chose le giec nous a
bien expliqué que si on n'arrivait pas à
diminuer significativement c'est à dire
à peu près de moitié les gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 on dépasserait les 1,5
degrés donc ça veut dire deux degrés
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est des vagues de chaleur c'est la
productivité de l'agriculture qui va
être perturbée cd et des océans qui vont
être perturbés au sens montée du niveau
mais aussi acidification et donc perte
de la biodiversité c'est la biodiversité
on entend que les insectes peuvent
disparaître dans un siècle
enfin il ya énormément de nouvelles
alarmantes et une passe rien et il se
passe rien donc c'est assez logique que
les mouvements continus s'amplifie et
quand je vois par exemple ce matin qu'il
y avait des mouvements de jeunes qui
sont allés faire pression sur la société
générale pour revendiquer que cette
banque
arrête d'investir dans les énergies
fossiles ça me paraît tout à fait
logique et je pense que ça va continuer
il n'y a pas de raison que ça s'arrête
il faut agir rapidement
ah oui oui on a quelques années c'est à
dire que quand on dit que il faut avoir
réduit les 2 50% les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici 2030
depuis la coop 21 les émissions
augmenter donc on n'est pas du tout sur
le bon chemin et on n'est pas du tout un
bon rythme et ça va pas se faire
instantanément donc nécessairement faut
bouger et très vite ces quelques années
un très vite c'est pas demain ces
quelques années mais on n'a pas dix ans
on n'a pas dix ans alors justement les
jeunes se mobilisent
face à cette grève des étudiants
aujourd'hui et jean michel blanquer air
a annoncé des débats dans tous les
lycées de la france de 16 heures à 18
heures des débats sur le climat que
pensez vous de cette annonce mais des
débats sur le climat il peut y en avoir
tous les jours donc pourquoi le faire le
jour où les jeunes ont décidé de se
mobiliser de faire une action visible de
faire une action collective
c'est totalement ridicule de proposer ça
ce jour-là que y ait des débats la
veille le lendemain dans les semaines à
venir tous les jours mais c'est simple
mais aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une
mesure totalement ridicule et gabriela
talent le secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer r s'est positionné pour cette
grève
justement alors que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale préfère plutôt des
débats dans les écoles dans un cadre
plus institutionnelle un paradoxe qui
illustre la difficulté vous pensez du
gouvernement à se saisir de cette
question environnementale
alors je sais pas si c'est des
dissensions internes au gouvernement
mais mais en fait l'important voit que
il ne se passe rien nicolas hulot à
démissionner maintenant à l'été l'année
dernière et il ne s'est rien passé donc
c'est ce qui a déclenché un certain
nombre de mouvements comme les marches
dont on va peut-être parler mais ces
îles le gouvernement aujourd'hui n'est
même pas dans les petits pas pour éviter
la crise de la biodiversité pour éviter
les gaz et les l'augmentation des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
on n'est vraiment pas dans ces choses là
on n'est pas non plus sur la diminution
des pesticides pour avoir une
alimentation saine on est pas du tout là
dedans aujourd'hui alors vous l'avez
rappelé la démission de nicolas hulot et
depuis la mobilisation da cessé de
grandir depuis cet été que proposez vous
à votre échelle en tant qu élue
écologiste à guyancourt
alors personnellement à guyancourt
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas en
responsabilité donc je suis élu je
participe au conseil municipal mais je
n'ai aucune prise sur les décisions donc
je ne peux pas changer quelque chose et
pourtant j'aurais bien envie de le faire
mais mais les collectivités locales de
manière générale que ce soit la ville
comme billancourt chaussée l'ua la
communauté d'agglo de 51,10 ville en
fête ont une responsabilité énorme
puisque par l'aménagement du territoire
par les transports en commun et
organisation des mobilités par les
investissements pour améliorer
l'efficacité énergétique pour lutter
contre la précarité énergétique
c'est-à-dire les gens qui n'arrivent pas
à se chauffer correctement toutes ces
actions là sont à la main des
collectivités locales donc c'est
vraiment un niveau où on peut faire
énormément de choses pour arriver à
tenir les engagements qui étaient ceux
qui avaient été pris pendant la coupe 21
alors justement en ce mois de mars des
mobilisations s'organisent partout en
france face à l'urgence environnementale
dans plus de 130 villes alternatiba
versailles et citoyen pour le climat
profite de la démarche avec leur
printemps pour le futur une marche se
tiendra ce samedi dans la cité royale
départ de la place d'armes à 11 heures
vous y serez bien entendu comme j'étais
aux deux précédentes à versailles comme
j'étais à celle de paris c'est
indispensable de montrer alors une
marche en soit c'est juste une
démonstration qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
intéressés
on a vu avec la pétition la sphère du
siècle qui demande à l'état d'intervenir
comme ça a été fait dans les pays bas
par exemple
donc on voit qu'il ya des millions donc
plus de deux millions deux millions cinq
ou de quelque chose comme ça aujourd'hui
de personnes qui se sont mobilisées en
disant oui c'est logique de traîner
l'état en justice parce que ils ne
tiennent pas leurs engagements pour le
climat donc c'est logique aussi qu' il
ya des milliers de gens qui aillent
encore plus loin c'est à dire marcher
dans la rue pour montrer qu'il faut
faire quelque chose pour faire pression
sur sur le gouvernement sur les élus
locaux et ensuite encore plus et il faut
continuer dans ce sens là et je le
rappelle rendez vous samedi à 11h devant
la place d'armes tout de suite on passe
au reste de l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
et des citoyens également engagé au sein
du collectif décidons ensemble à
guyancourt des habitants organisent des
ateliers et des rencontres ouvert à tous
vie locale logement environnement
éducation sont des thèmes abordés les
membres se réunissent dans le but de
présenter une liste participative pour
les élections municipales de 2020 avec
une priorité celle de la démocratie
participative
le collectif se laisse jusqu'à septembre
pour construire leur programme avant de
constituer une liste candidate pour le
scrutin
écoutez ses membres est une initiative
qui est parti de deux citoyens
citoyennes de la ville sous investis en
milieu associatif y en avait plus tôt
dans l'est on va dire souvent militants
dans l'économie sociale et solidaire
la transition écologique aux médias il
ya beaucoup de questions qui tournent en
démocratie participative comment est-ce
qu'on mettra en oeuvre
la démarche de démocratie participative
parce que je suis en cours une échelle
particulière on n'applique pas la même
manière suivant les échelles de guide
ensuite les question c'est comment qu'on
créera le programme comme on réalise
comment pouvoir fait en sorte que tous
les citoyens puissent apporter leur
pierre à l'édifice
comment pouvoir me faire en sorte que
chaque chaque idée puis souhaite
valoriser sur le sens profond
olivier paréja vous est également membre
du collectif est décidé ensemble à
guyancourt en 2014 vous étiez élu au
conseil municipal sur la liste de
l'ancien maire socialiste françois de
ligne et marie-christine le tarnec a
pris la suite la mère de guyancourt qui
n'a toujours pas indiqué si elle était
candidate à un nouveau mandat
si c'est le cas est ce que vous allez
être adversaires pour sept prochaines
municipales
la question n'est pas tant d'états deux
adversaires pardon notre idée c'est que
il ya besoin et c'est à lui en cours
mais c'est de manière très générale il
ya besoin comme aldric l'a dit dans
l'interview de démocratie participative
c'est à dire de redonner la parole aux
gens ils peuvent être consultés il peut
ce qu participé à l'élaboration des
projets il ya beaucoup de villes moi
j'ai la chance d'avoir effectivement été
élus en 2014 et d'avoir dans des
formations vu énormément de villes dans
lesquelles il y avait des démarches qui
avaient été mises en oeuvre
on parle du village de saillans on parle
de la ville de grenoble on parle de la
région centre val de loire dont
énormément d'endroits où les citoyens
les citoyennes ont été impliqués de
façon à construire les projets et
ensuite les élus les mettre en oeuvre et
c'est ça qu'on a vraiment envie de
pousser pour faire un changement et
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
dans l'esprit on a bien vu avec les
gilets jaunes qui réclamait un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne par
exemple on a vu avec la participation
grands débats malgré tout les limites de
l'exercice mais il ya quand même eu des
gens qui sont allés parce qu'ils avaient
envie de s'exprimer parce qu'ils avaient
envie de participer
eh ben c'est justement ça qu'on veut
faire parce que à l'échelle locale c'est
probablement l'endroit où c'est le plus
facile de commencer et puis on verra
après politique toujours le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer air était en déplacement dans
les yvelines ce jeudi
il s'est rendu dans une école de la
celle les bordes une visite dans le
cadre de la semaine des mathématiques
avec pour ambition également de défendre
l'importance de l'instruction
obligatoire est des 3 en reportage
d'aurélie rose dans cette classe de
petite et moyenne sections de la celle
les bordes on apprend à compter à faire
de la musique ou encore à faire des
constructions sans être perturbés par la
présence de jean michel blanquer
avec ce déplacement le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a voulu montrer le
caractère majeur de l'école maternelle
une mesure qu'il défend dans le projet
de loi sur l'école de la confiance
adopté en février dernier en première
lecture par l'assemblée nationale par
les d'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans
c'est tout simplement dire que oui
l'école commença à trois ans et que les
premières années il faut les prendre
très au sérieux il faut y aller il faut
certes le faire au travers de jeux de
musique de chose qui corresponde à cette
école de la confiance dont je parle
souvent cette école compte 87 élèves de
la petite section au cm2 et joue un rôle
clé dans ce territoire rural des
yvelines
c'est ce qu'a voulu réaffirmer l'équipe
enseignante lors d'une table ronde
ici on est une famille que ça soit les
parents les enseignants la municipalité
tout le monde travaille ensemble on se
connaît tous et c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important dans le cadre de
la semaine des mathématiques jean michel
blanquer a également voulu souligner
l'importance de cette matière à l'école
et ce dès le plus jeune âge messi s'est
retrouvé une petite bille dans le
dans le sac est nommé le nombre et après
retrouver le maillot qui est accroché et
qui face cachée quand tous les maillots
sont retournés celui qui a le ps be a
gagné un exercice ludique qui
visiblement plaît aux enfants avec 7 aux
écoles de la confiance et sa mesure
phare l'instruction obligatoire dès 3
ans le ministre de l'éducation nationale
a réaffirmé sa volonté de lutter contre
les inégalités sociales en notre
ministre s'est déplacé dans les yvelines
à mardi matin un christophe castaner
était à vélizy villacoublay pour la
cérémonie de translation du drapeau des
crs l'occasion également de rendre
hommage ses fonctionnaires et de
réaffirmer son soutien aux forces de
l'ordre en plein contexte de
mobilisation et d gilet jaune
revue des troupes pour le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner et son
secrétaire d'état laurent nunez ses
fonctionnaires font partie d'un corps
spécialisé de la police nationale les
crs tous les ans la direction zonale des
crs paris basé à vélizy villacoublay
accueille la cérémonie de translation du
drapeau
cette année c'est la zone sud est qui a
passé le drapeau à la zone est
[Musique]
christophe castaner on a également
profité pour réaffirmer son soutien aux
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
en première ligne ces dernières semaines
avec le mouvement des gilet jaune
nous avons souhaité être là tous les
deux pour être aux côtés aux côtés des
crs crs qui sont sur le terrain du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre qui sont là pour
protéger les français
j'ai souhaité aussi porter ce message
d'exigence ce message d'exigence
vis-à-vis d'un comportement qui ne doit
rien céder à l'éthique
le ministre de l'intérieur a remis des
médailles pour acte de courage et de
dévouement
avec un budget de la police nationale en
hausse en 2010 9 christophe castaner a
également évoqué des mesures à venir
notamment pour les 600 fonctionnaires de
vélizy on fait partie intégrante du plan
immobilier que nous avons lancé 900
millions d'euros entre 2018 et 2020 et
vous en verrez les effets ici même à
vélizy ou un nouveau cantonnement de
passage doit être créé
ces lieux permettent de mieux recevoir
les compagnies de passage qui seront
plus nombreuses à vélizy pour les jeux
olympiques en 2024
c'était fin février un million de litres
de pétrole déversés dans des champs et
des cours d'eaux à haute ou yé et vic
conséquences de la rupture d'une pipe
line ile-de-france de total
depuis le groupe s'affaire à remettre en
état les terres agricoles touchées par
l'écoulement d'hydrocarbures le chantier
global devrait prendre plusieurs mois
reportage au sein de ce chantier et de
dépollution
ils sont installés ici pour plusieurs
mois les équipes de dépollution sont à
pied d'oeuvre pour nettoyer le lieu de
l'incident plusieurs champs agricoles
ont été touchés par l'écoulement des 900
mètres cubes de pétrole derrière nous
nous avons des hydro cureur qui sont en
train de pomper les arrivées de rocard
bur qui sont collectés par les drones et
dans les piscines que nous avons creusé
dans des tranchées avec la phase de
nettoyage les équipes se penche aussi
sur le 'pipeline' après avoir extrait
est mis sous scellés pour l'anc est le
morceau à l'origine de la fuite
la réparation a commencé ainsi que la
dépollution des terres les champs
là-haut ceux qui sont prennent la fuite
eux sont pollués c'est là bas qu'on va
devoir excavés c'est à dire retirer les
terres et les déposer à côté sur un
liner et les envoyer ensuite en
dépollution et comme le traitement va
prendre du temps
nous on viendra avec les terres de
substitution et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
déjà des discussions avec la chambre
d'agriculture avec ses agriculteurs pour
connaître quelles sont les
caractéristiques que vous avez dans ce
hall qu'on vous donne les mêmes termes
le chantier s'organisent en
collaboration avec les différentes
parties prenantes notamment les élus
locaux
nous avons pris un arrêté également de
l'interdiction de se servir des puits
pour l'instant c'est un arrêté pris par
précaution une précaution prise aussi à
vic sur ce bassin à l'entrée du village
les hydrocarbures sont concentrées grâce
à la vanne guillotine pour faciliter le
travail de nettoyage et éviter
l'extension de la pollution facilité
depuis le champ par le système de
drainage le champ été drainés donc ce
sont des petits tuyaux qui sont dans le
sol qui sont ensuite renvoyés vers le
rue d'habitude ce sont des réseaux de
drains qui permettent aux agriculteurs
de ne pas avoir trop d'eau dans leurs
champs la stratégie dans laquelle on
s'inscrit c'est vraiment d'enlever les
accumulations de pau lyon et restant
libre donc en surface que l'on peut
récupérer collecter aisément pour
libérer au maximum le milieu du pot lyon
et d'installer régulièrement des points
de contrôle la durée de l'ensemble des
travaux est estimé entre 6 et 8 mois
un calendrier qui pourraient être
affinée total s'engage à indemniser les
personnes impactées et à réhabiliter les
zones des chantiers quelles sont les
conséquences de cette fuite pour
l'environnement va nécessairement les
zones directement impactés mais
également aussi toutes les zones en aval
de la mauldre même même jusqu'à la scène
il ya potentiellement un risque est là
il faut absolument qu'ils aient une
expertise indépendante qui en plus de ce
que va dire total puisse nous conforter
sur le fait qu' il n'y a pas de risque
pour les riverains pour les agriculteurs
de manière générale merci olivier paréja
d'avoir été notre invité je le rappelle
vous êtes conseiller municipal
écologiste à guyancourt
merci
la 14e édition de la semaine nationale
du rein s'achève ce samedi organisé par
france rend cette semaine de prévention
propose des dépistages gratuits et
anonymes sur tout le territoire français
reportage au sein de la clinique de
saint germain en laye l'insuffisance
rénale l'une des priorités de la
nouvelle stratégie de santé qui souhaite
notamment développer la prévention de
cette maladie chronique francs sera un
propose des dépistages gratuits et
anonymes comme ici à la clinique de
saint germain en laye ça permet de
dépister assez tôt les maladies et de
prendre en charge et de faire un suivi
régulier
les patients doivent le faire une fois
par an bah c'était l'occasion et je
crois que c'est une bonne opportunité
parce qu'effectivement amont un jeune je
pensais pas forcément ce dépistage 10h10
examen rapide des questions sont au
programme
c'est important de prendre et vérifier
la tension pour justement détecter les
maladies cardiaques et également rénale
on leur demande s'ils aussi ils ont des
antécédents familiaux parce que ça joue
beaucoup et puis on fait un recueil de
données donc on l'est pèse on prend leur
glycémie leur tour de taille et puis on
leur demande d'uriner dans un pot
boufarik bandelette urinaire
le service de dialyse de la clinique de
saint germain en laye accueille environ
40 personnes par jour pour une dialyse
de trois à cinq heures suivant la
corpulence de la personne un dépistage
précoce permet une prise en charge
appropriée
le test urinaire permet de détecter
toute trace de sang ou encore de
leucocytes suivant la couleur
ben contre on trempe la bandelette dans
le green
suivant cette bandelette la machine nous
détecte tous les problèmes qui peut y
avoir ou pas de problème la maladie
rénale est dite silencieuse elle ne se
manifeste par aucun symptôme perceptible
en france plus d'un tiers des personnes
entrent en urgence en traitement de
suppléance greffe ou dialyse le rhin qui
ne fonctionne plus donc on compense
cette
cette pathologie en filtrant en fait le
sang de la personne en éliminant l'eau
et les électrolytes ou toxiques pour
l'organisme
cette quatorzième semaine nationale du
rein vise plus largement à sensibiliser
le grand public aux problématiques
relatives aux maladies rénales
je pense qu'il importe important de
sensibiliser les gens à toutes les
maladies parce qu'on n'en parle jamais
le nombre de malades concernés par
l'insuffisance rénale augmentent de 2 %
par an c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo
passer un excellent week end
[Musique]